you're gonna be absolutely disgusted
after you hear how evil Starbucks is
Starbucks needs billions of coffee beans
a year to keep their empire running so
they get their coffee beans from poor
third world countries the problem is
growing coffee takes a ridiculous amount
of water every cup of coffee produced
requires 39 gallons of water that's why
a huge chunk of the global Water Supply
is being used just for coffee production
the ironic part is that the countries
that are the biggest coffee producers
are usually the ones that don't have
enough clean drinking water for their
populace Uganda produced over 5 million
bags of coffee in 2020 yet many
communities there still rely on swamps
ponds rivers and unprotected springs for
water Ethiopian citizens have less clean
drinking water than almost any other
country on the planet more than half of
the population doesn't have basic access
to drinking water and yet somehow it
still manages to scrape together enough
water to be the fifth biggest coffee
producer in the world which is why